toronto vous savez ont soulevé les
foules en remportant le championnat de
la nba
le mois dernier ils ont mis la main sur
le trophée larry o'brien et nous sommes
chanceux ce matin madame messieurs le
montréalais kris boucher est avec nous
avec le trophée avec lui bonjour crise
vous savez ça va bien et vous savez
d'abord fois on voit très bien le
trophée donc la vie o'brien que vous
promener comme ça à montréal c'est ainsi
pour deux jours je vais avoir longé si
le faire le plus de monde le voit prix
célébrer avec moi championnat alors
c'est amusant et puis je contacte on
al'opportunité de l'avoir réussi à
moulins c'est quoi le programme
justement de cette dernière ne m'ont
jamais dit je dois aller aux portes au
parc carignan
je pense que la première diffusion puis
après on n'a pas un avis les belges
aussi pour les jeunes
puis après c'est par champs dorés et
puis je pense aussi à 6h puis je pense
que c'est la dernière diffusion pour le
trophée vous prenez photo vous passer
les journées avec le trophée vous allez
montrer aux jeunes de votre quartier de
montréal-nord ça représente quoi pour
vous qui avez grandi à montréal dans un
milieu pas facile pas évident de revenir
en ville avec le trophée juste que je
pense que c'est possible d'arriver
quelque part je pense que c'est ça que
j'essaie de montreux-jeune j'aiderai la
possibilité de voir que moi je n'avais
rien au début et puis j'ai la chance de
nos champions puis je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui moi j'ai commencé
tard je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qu'ils ont 13 14 ans puis dans la
chance de s'améliorer et puis faire
mieux que moi qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
alors je pensais juste pour ouvrir des
yeux puis j'ai fait célébrer avec tout
le monde à montréal avant par une votre
championnat de la saison de ce qui s'en
vient pour vous accueillir un moment
dans votre carrière qui a été vraiment
déterminant dans votre parcours le goût
ça vraiment été charnière de dire ah oui
je pourrais me rendre plus loin grâce au
basket bat je pense que quand je suis
partie 2
mémorable à prendre fois je pense que
c'est l'action avoir les yeux qu'il aime
la chance de faire quelque chose de
spécial
je me suis toujours dit si je quitte ma
famille je vais quitter ma famille peut
demeurer pour les mêmes raisons pis pour
exceller alors je pense que c'était
vraiment un signe pour moi quand j'ai
réalisé que j'ai quitté ce prier pour
jour parce que vous avez vous étiez avec
les oies rieuses la saison précédente
ils ont gagné le championnat
les ruptures ils ont gagné le
championnat les saisons suivantes quand
vous êtes arrivé en a qui disent que
vous êtes peut-être une enquête chez moi
c'est ça que vous comptez cette équipe
là c'est quoi la différence entre ces
deux championnats pour vous je pense que
la première année je sais plus s'il le
fait que j'ai pas vraiment joué mais
j'ai la chance de voir mais ma deuxième
année je pense que j'ai fait beaucoup
durant l'année puis je pense que c'est
ça qui m'a vraiment fait que on demande
c'est de ces championnats est beaucoup
plus important le fait que jeter au
canada avec le rap tueuse
quand j'ai gagné j'ai l'impression que
tout le canada et ganivet montréal avait
gagné aussi et puis je pense à sa maman
ça m'importe si vous venez me chercher
au cas juste parce que ya pas beaucoup
de gens qui vient du canada qui jouait
dans l'équipe canadienne pigalle
championnat je pense que ça m'a fait du
bien quand on a gagné
revenons sur cette victoire avez vous
été surpris un de soulèvement de la
foule vous aviez déjà des milliers de
personnes de rien notre autre ici à
montréal
est ce que ça vous a surpris autant
merci pas au début je pense que toute
l'année on a eu beaucoup de support
alors je pense que je vois qu'on était
surpris mais je pense que quand les plus
à fond commence et c'est vrai on a
vraiment vu un autre niveau de support
voit ce que gagner perdre et ça
dérangeait pas le monde y est on a vu du
moins qui étaient là deux jours avant
que les game commence
du moins qui font du bruit qui aura 100
c'était vraiment fou pour moi des jeux
voir ça de mes de mes propres et puis
après tout cas c'est la même chose à
montréal plus d'avoir deux millions de
personnes à la parade puis s'excuse
d'être une heure et demie je pense
qu'elle est elle dans un apparent 6
heures c'était vraiment
un gros changement est ce que vous êtes
de santé un peu de votre nuage après
cette victoire qui est descendu en
peluche qui attaché à mon rêve en
revenant à montréal puis le jugement
l'excitation puis tout alors je pense
que j'ai encore dans un nuage d'encens
sont impressionnés en faut le voir comme
ça mais on le voit la belle avait su
vous voyez pas la prendre des photos
comme ça et de prendre des photos
également donc de cusset et du du
trophée ça mais c'est le fun le trophée
vous promener avec aujourd'hui vous êtes
en haut dans la célébration de la saison
dernière mais vous êtes aussi dans la
préparation de la saison suivante a été
nommé sur une des deux équipes des
toiles de la ligue d'été de la nba vous
avez été invité aussi au camp
d'entraînement en vue du prochain
championnat du monde de l'envié comment
ça rejaillit sur votre carrière mais
aussi sur le basket ball au québec vous
succès je pense que c'est juste j'essaie
un procès
tu peux voir les étapes qu'il faut
qu'ils fassent pour accéler même pour
moi pour excès mais pour moi je pense
que c'est juste le fait que j'ai
toujours voulu avoir la chance de faire
quelque chose de spécial pour pas juste
pour moi mais pour ma famille et puis
pour les gens qui me regardent puis je
pense qu'avec un championnat tous c'est
beaucoup juste de montrer qu'il ya un
prix à la fin puis a pris comme ça
n'arrive pas souvent
effectivement puis pour les jeunes m'ont
réellement ça veut dire croise parce que
y en a beaucoup qui joue au basket barre
de plus en plus au québec où un support
qui est pratiqué par une minorité mais
heureusement que la majorité se rend
compte que ça existe le basket ça veut
dire une fois pour le quartier je pense
que c'est ça oblige yeux juste pour
préparer pas les parents ou les
adolescents qui joue en ce moment
juste le savoir que c'est passé moi j'ai
commencé j'avais 19 ans puis je pense
que si je peux ouvrir des idées des gens
ils ont 16 ans ou une mère qui a fuit ce
qui veut dire que c'est possible je
pense que c'est peut être utilisé en
tant qu'ils ont parce que moi c'est
comme ça je me suis senti au début je me
suis dit acheter trop vieux puits to be
gérer ça arrive et puis ménagers
champions pays je pense que ça peut
vraiment beaucoup de jeunes tous avec
simplon universitaire en plus
n'oubliez pas les joueurs participent à
l'école je peux vous sentez que vous
avez maintenant leur chance d'inspirer
vraiment plusieurs gens je compte je
compte continuer à inspirer juste pas
toujours basket mais je pense que en
faisant des camps en dhr en aidant les
jeunes défavorisés et où je pense que ça
va vraiment m'aider aider les jeunes
jouent au basket c'est une chose mais
redonner je pensais vraiment important
pour moi juste parce que on m'a donné
une chance puis je veux donner la chance
aux jeunes aussi c'est moi j'aurais aimé
50 sans avoir un modèle comme c'est
merci beaucoup pour votre passage très
impressionnant merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous d'avoir amené également le
trophée avec vous ça impressionne déjà
merci beaucoup pour tout perdu